so it's going to be your task to add a
task to send a confirmation email the
first thing you need to do is add the
send confirmation email servlet to your
project and it goes in the servlet
package you can get this servlet
completely fully coded from the lesson 5
folder or you can write it yourself as
you like and then you need to make sure
that you configure your send
confirmation email servlet in web.xml
then you need to update the create
conference function in conference API
you need to add the functionality to add
the task to the task queue whenever
anybody creates a conference and if you
like you can also update this function
to use transactions so that the profile
and the conference entities get saved
together and the task gets added to the
task queue and that all happens inside a
transaction or none of it happens and
you can get the template code to add to
create conference from the lesson 5
folder if you want or you can try
writing it yourself from scratch so you
can optionally put the code to create
the conference inside a transaction when
you add the task to the queue in create
conference function you can use the
default queue or you can use a named
queue it's up to you but if you use a
named queue you need to make sure to
configure the queue in queued or XML you
can also use the default queue but
configure it to use other options like
change the rate or change the retry
options and again if you want to do that
you need to configure it in Q dot XML in
that case you would just add a queue
name default to Q dot XML so the
development server running on localhost
does not send emails it does add tasks
to queues and actually has its own
simple task queue viewer but it won't
actually send an email so if you want to
test the sending of emails you're going
to need to deploy your application to
appspot so when you've done testing it
on localhost as much as you can go ahead
and deploy it to appspot and then to
test it of course you're going to need
to create a new conference and then
check your email to make sure that the
email arrived did you get an email and
then go ahead and explore your task
queues in the admin console to check off
each of these steps as you do them